[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm Linc this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're tackling the question
what if our dogs died oh really why sit
down a toast actually you know we had a
scare with Jade I will say she is fine
and we had a scare with Barbara
incidentally and when I told you I
wanted to talk about a scary I didn't
tell you what this care was for to save
it for the podcast that's how I we live
our lives and you're gonna tell me about
your scare with Barbara so just based on
knowing that we both have scares I think
we will unpack the the imminent death of
our dogs not not don't not like and well
eminence not the right word that seems
like it's rapidly appro here's the thing
did you read the secret you ever read
the secret I've never read it but lots
of people have did you slide it to me on
a sheet of paper no hey [ __ ] and I
think if you believe the things that are
written in the secret and then Oprah
endorsed it so it must be true then then
you if you say things that can happen so
you just said imminent death of our dogs
and now you've got me repeating it are
you saying we're speak were manifesting
and manifest so we need to unmanifest
that the the immortal activity of our
dog the yeah the immortality of our
dog's immortality of our dogs our dogs
will live forever our dogs will never
die our dogs are safe our dogs will
never die all dogs Dinah fest that Oprah
not all dogs truly live by the way any
time Oprah would like to come on she is
welcome we don't do guests anymore man
we'd do anything for Oprah but will we I
would would you execute Barbara for
Oprah again that's not I would do
question I would do anything for Oprah
but I wouldn't do that
gosh and you know meatloaf
yeah that's his song never got in a
meatloaf but someone almost bought me a
meatloaf record which is the other thing
I want to talk about well I also take a
step back and stay I need to unpack my
41st birthday I want to do that in this
episode
I know you're interested in how I
celebrated I'd Oved our group into the
birthday hole and I came out forty-one
came out forty-one how's it feel I've
been there for a while so I I'll also
give you an update on that even though
you were at the party Rhett I don't
wanna I was I can give you my
perspective on the party I can give a
partygoers perspective on your 41st
birthday party okay okay we're gonna
kind of catch up with each other again
the thing that we're only gonna Center
on is the immortality of our dogs and if
for some reason they turn out to not be
as immortal as we think that they are
and we manifest in Oprah's name then how
would we respond and we will tell these
stories of their near deaths which I
have not heard yours you ever heard mine
no that's right but do you want it what
do you want to talk about first because
I got another law you had like a I got a
little thing that I'm yeah that I'm
working on that I just want to I want to
process give a project a summer time is
it a popsicle for it I think you because
you you even when we made the pub so go
for it yeah going up yeah yeah and you
this is Richard
this is a church project remember they
took that room the small room upstairs
in blue-screen
it was dedicated to a potty the only
thing in there was a popsicle for it
it's pretty awesome and you were so
proud of it and I would go in and
disassemble it on a regular basis I was
wondering who did that I'd be like I
don't need that we don't need that
that's not what I was gonna talk about
I'm sorry
you ain't said he had a project I
thought it might be a popsicle for I
don't know if he's technically
summertime I don't know I don't know
when this comes out but to my mind we're
in summertime because for sure we are my
kids are out of school
that's summertime we're in summertime as
this is being recorded
I think is the technical first day of
summer which is our first day at or I
don't go by official stuff like that but
when the kids get out of school you know
when the traffic gets or the lighter in
LA it becomes summertime he's starting
to think what am I gonna do different
what am I gonna do different
yeah shave my beard a little bit shorter
this morning summer beard 624 oh so what
is the release date of this welcome
welcome
summer summer solstice sea house right
so I'm I'm thinking of ways that I can
like in Bray
summer and so this morning I thought I'd
try something new on for size literally
do you have it all right now yeah it's
down here you see that look at you see
my shoe
only you can see it red not even of
YouTube viewers can see it's just a
normal shoe yeah but look down at the
edge you see down in the shoe what's
down in that shoe I can't honestly can't
see into the shoe my foots in this year
yeah but what else is in this year oh
you're sockless I'm going sockless today
because I walked out my my these shoes
are down there at my garage but I I got
to do some planning to put my socks on
up in my bedroom if there's no socks
waiting death if I don't sometimes I'll
take my socks off when I take my shoes
off and I'll coming in a house either in
bedroom slippers like a 50s dad Televisa
calm dad but on my bedroom slippers or
I'll just be barefoot but I guess
yesterday I didn't have I didn't I
didn't take off my socks with my shoes I
put them in the in the laundry upstairs
sorry if this is too detailed but then
when I came down today I assumed there
would be old socks there that I could
just reuse there weren't I was like you
know what I'm doing it but you know why
humor time no but you know I didn't go
in sockless we had a conversation about
the fact that I've been wearing shiny
new don't say this I knew you were gonna
say that yesterday we had a conversation
about it yeah you're gonna take credit
not a sponsor you gonna put your shoe up
on the table I got these shoes off yup
here you don't what's not anywhere near
you I these shoes don't require fleas
are probably jumping off they don't
require socks and I'm not even gonna
mention what they are if they want to be
a sponsor then we'll talk about them
expensively I've seen again we I saw
yeah we talked about it you see the ads
on Instagram then you buy the shoes and
I looked at the ads but these are
designed to not have socks your shoes
are not designed to have sucked I'm not
saying you have to buy these shoes I'm
this way all right you can't I think you
did influence me because I'm like I've
always wanted didn't wear shoes without
socks I don't feel good it always feels
like
uh it should feel good and now I see
people who do it I'm envious I'm like
man you should try these on
that person is trotting around sockless
it must be summertime it must be spring
it must be fall it could be any time of
year but it you just seemed freer and
I'm envious of that yeah you should be
and I'm like I can't do that cuz the
foots wet well how do you feel at this
point in the middle of the afternoon not
good at all yeah within five minutes of
putting them on I walk out to the car
yeah and I was like I gotta turn around
I gotta go all the way upstairs and I
gotta fetch socks you make it seem like
you have it you live in a mansion that
is gonna take a significant amount of
time to get upstairs it would take you
17 seconds to get to your bedroom well
there's I mean there's there's 14 steps
man yes that's at least 17 seconds just
to get up the stairs you're getting a
safe manner pretty slow I'll do three
steps at a time I'm along let it long
like it beasts anyway I'm just I it's
not working I mean I just want to be one
of those people so yeah my 15 year old
son who is not a dork okay and also he
can't he knows what school he wears the
cool stuff he likes him I said what do
you think about these alike they look
good if Kanye come out with these exact
shoes you would think they were awesome
I think those look good but you can't
wear without socks
what is that commercial II don't stink
though what well it's day one what are
those called what's the name of those
adidas I 5923 smell of it I don't I know
I don't need to smell of that no no no I
don't need to i smell of yours
that's Miller Oprah shoes I smell years
only on that that video we may put you
over doesn't wear socks do you feel like
you would sweat in normal shoes but not
dose that would sweat like crazy and you
don't sweat there's no way you don't
sweat it's just wikked away or something
bingo is called moisture wicking it's
constantly being wicks man if you're
being wicks how do you you don't think
about this wet do you feel freer but I
feel like I mean wick to constantly my
feet are just
and wick now I have in fact I don't
translate that into pleasure well I've
got a new movie coming out John wick for
I don't know what I'm just asking what
positive benefits do you receive from
having your feet weight because III am I
feel like I know that they're there I
didn't articulate one less step in the
morning I thought you would appreciate
that yeah
extreme comfort and I think I think
showing a little ankle it's a little bit
sexy you wear hey yeah you wear you wear
no-show socks that's what I do but the
problem with the no-show socks is that
they bind my touch they're so tight on
my toes you got to get the right brand I
picked up some notes whole opening
sounds like an ad let's go ahead and
talk about note yes so I picked up some
no-show socks
it's it Aldo or Aldo Aldo that place the
shoe store Aldo I think I'll do Aldo we
were in there with mild oh you go dad
you don't know how to say it when my
brother was in town and like we went in
there for something and I got there ones
that they it was like oh this is a
really good price it was like three
pairs for like eleven bucks which is
it's this whole podcast a commercial
this isn't a commercial don't get
offended talking about products that you
are enjoying in life and then talking
crap about them is definitely not a
commercial this is a warning if anything
don't if you have sighs oh you know well
feet don't get the Aldo socks that they
sell for a good price because the things
were so tight that literally at a ball
three pairs in a pack you lost a toe
every single pair in in a listen I'm
talking I got trimmed toenails it wasn't
my toenails busting through I tried my
trim my toenails on a regular basis now
cuz I never know when I'm gonna show up
they're gonna be like we need to show
your feet on the camera today you really
really like you are bitter today no I'm
not bitter I'm very happy I've seen I've
watched seven hours of Oprah right
before I just was on the Oprah channel
the anyway
my toe busted through the sock in one
day like by the afternoon I get home I
take my shoe off and my toes a busted
through
but if you get just the I don't even
know what brand it is because this is
not commercial but just I got someone
Amazon those have lasted forever and
they also have this little thing that
like grips tobacco you're a full rubber
thang got some of those but they're
still tight and you got to go size up
you know how about you if the Expo
busting through check yeah you busted
through the whole thing
these shoes look at that my toe busted
through the my big toe busted through
the end of in the right first week yeah
we can wearing these but I liked him so
much I bought another pair anyway is
that the other pair no this is the new
pair didn't bust through you still I
still I wore these without socks because
I wasn't not about to wear my my go to
shoes and funk them up I this was an
experiment man
adidas would think Jesus would have
replaced those by the way we know from
no charge you I know but you have to
complain and time is money complaint is
time and time is money and okay
I spent no time just ordered another
pair of shoes ironically so is your
project that you were talking about you
not wearing shoes socks bingo
who can play bingo okay that's it huh
huh well I didn't say that it was some I
I didn't think it was a worthy of a
opening conversation but it looks like
we've had it no I'm I'm just saying that
I want to know if I should press on you
know not if they don't wick because you
does it give you that like reggae vibe
like all of a sudden you're like
laid-back if it does not wick you must
have quit if it does not wick you must
suck it if it does not wick you must not
commit yeah you don't have wicking shoes
man you can't do it you got to put socks
on if you're interested in some wicking
shoes just ask me I'll tell you where I
got these let's get into let's get into
more weighty matters speaking of wicking
we're selling no-show socks that are the
right size and we're selling that hats
that wicks that I don't think the Hat
wigs but let's act like the Hat wick is
that whisking hat that hat wicks your
moisture from the
your comes out of your head if you've
got a head moisture problems then this
hat is perfectly designed for that it
will wick wick it right away and send it
into the atmosphere it's also a
camouflage and has an orange emblem
never used to word emblem on anything
that we talked about you just say logo
so if you're so if so deer season is
coming up in the fall in the fall if why
don't your voice get nasal in the fall
deer seasons coming up in the fall if
you want to wear that hat because the
deer cannot see the orange but the
hunters keep the hunters can is that one
hundreds wear orange because only
hunters can see it they wear deer
hunters wear orange because they don't
want to be shot by other hunters yes
and a deer are color blind and so it all
just blends in but the reason that it's
camouflage Orange is because it breaks
up the visual pattern which still serves
as camouflage because it breaks up the
lines that's why it's orange camo I
never thought I honestly I thought it
was they were you you thought they were
attracting deer with orange clothes no I
just thought that they had they they
were just taking one for the team as a
disadvantage it was like I'm willing I'm
willing to wear orange to not get shot
by another hunter even though it makes
me more visible to deer I've for some
reason I've thought that's how it well
if you're hunting dove and hold on are
you are you true this I'm are you true
in this okay well do you actually know
or are you B essing well let me just put
it this way I have known this since I
was a child but that may not make it
right it just means I've grown up in the
culture of North Carolina a hunting
culture knowing this to be true but I've
never fat you've assumed it I think it's
true okay and and I don't know why
I will readily admit some rednecks home
in Assumption alright Jacob has pulled
up a fact deer are essentially red-green
color blind like some humans their
colour vision is limited to short blue
and middle green wavelength color yes
what about orange that means they can't
see are
that's why you can wear it however you
can't in fact it is stupid for hunters
to not wear aren't are there so many
hunter let me get this out it's the law
you have to wear orange if you hunt deer
if you don't it's illegal okay that is
the law in most states or all states
that we thought dear the second thing is
one time but I've seen on my don't rain
yeah cuz I let me just finish the damn
sentence man it's more than one sentence
the point multiple sentences uh my dad
used to take us dove honey would you
edit your bitter today I'm not but I'm
losing a good mood man but you won't let
me talk do you cannot see blaze orange
the same way that humans can see it
likely appears brown or gray to deer but
we got to ask a deer to know now police
the reason that you see hunters not wear
orange is because they're bird hunters
and birds like dove can see orange in
fact one of the times my dad
we took a guy hunting with us growing up
we never hunt a deer we hunted of the
symbol of peace and this guy who came
along in the group wore an orange shirt
and my dad was like what the hell are
you doing man you can't wear orange is
not deer hunting the dove see orange
they've got better sight than we do so
ironically and it was he shoot him so he
killed the guy and then we went hunting
it made it easier to get shot at because
he was wearing alright
huh the birds hmm that makes sense and
that's why I was construing all hunters
together and assuming that the ones who
were orange are just safer yeah but
they're hunting different things yeah
exactly
if I don't let you talk yeah I would
have learned that yeah this is a bonus
for the video mythical dodge store deer
aren't gonna see this but birds are but
that's not and I'm talking about the
emblem that I'm pointing at I don't
think that's legal though you think you
gotta it's gotta be predominantly orange
I don't think it could just have an
orange emblem whoa do you see that I
suck all the way down cuz I hit my foot
is now caught under my chair mmm sorry
do you want to start talking about the
dogs or do you want to work towards the
dogs because I kind of feel like we
should work towards the dogs yeah let's
because we're gonna talk about I'll give
an idea my birthday the emotional
quotient yeah cuz I mean turn if 40 was
a big deal we both had big parties you
can go back and listen to those
respective ear biscuits about those two
events 41 does not warrant that big of
an event 41 does not warrant an entire
podcast conversation says what's not
getting one ain't gonna get it
basically you it just warrants the fact
that if you are already having to get
together there's like a standing event
every month you got a game night there
basically you know a lot of our friends
come to I'm not gonna say every single
one of my friends you commandeered my
game night as your birthday party Jessi
graciously texted and said hey our next
game night falls on Lynx birthday yep so
do you guys want to do that as his
birthday it's totally up to you I was
like yeah that's a good idea I didn't
mind at all you were hurt a little hurt
by that I brought my games over to your
house we did Jessi was flying out of
town by the way so it like it actually
helped we didn't play any of the games
and you still haven't I'll get today I
left my games there would you just let
me talk about birthday so yeah I was
very appreciative to like basically we
already had an invitation list everybody
was already expecting to show up
somewhere I was like made it very simple
so they come over and I was like well
you know what I did the one thing about
birthday parties how am I have one even
if it is just 41 I kind of would like
presents this is me talking to Chris
this is not as crazy dull thing to say
Kristi's like this isn't what 40 people
over and I'm gonna say they don't have
to bring gifts I was like whoa whoa
let's discuss I'm like I kind of would
like gifts and I'm like you know what
I'm gonna make it easy and affordable
for people I'm gonna be like I would
honestly what
really like is like records to add to my
record collection and your why you just
give me a used record you can get one
for like four bucks it can be a it can
be an expression of what well as my
friend hold on I would like you're
taking what you say see what I told her
well you weren't there what your wife
sent an email out okay and your wife
made it sound like it was her idea what
she said was is that you know what you
don't have to bring a gift she took one
for the team you don't you don't have to
she made it tactful but yeah that you
were not about to do right so she said
you don't have to bring a gift but if do
bring a gift
he's always looking to beef up his
record collection right that's a
paraphrase I think your wife used the
term beef up I don't think I've ever
heard her say that but you know you know
because I am beefed-up right you already
beefed up she doesn't say you need to be
fun sometimes she'll say I've noticed
that you're maintaining your beef duck
or staying beefed up is did you notice
when you showed up you wanted the first
people to show up because you're my best
friend yeah I gotta be there to help I
show up first and by the way didn't get
you used records and didn't get you I
got you like six records that's right I
spent like $200 I notice that I did
notice for your birthday just so you
just so you know I'll have to post if
you want to know my records all you have
to follow me on Instagram link lamont
lots of shoutouts uh I'll share a few of
them but did you notice when you said
that it reminded me of the Golden Girls
theme song which goes how does it begin
if you tell me the beginning I know how
does it start
what did I say well thank you for being
a friend traveled down the road and back
again your heart is true you're a pal
and a confidante and if you threw a
party and invited everyone
oh you would see the the greatest gift
yeah the greatest gift would be from me
from me you would see the greatest gift
would be from me and the card attached
would say thank you for being a friend
but Martin you know what you did attach
a card but it said happy birthday it did
and it had Jesse from Breaking Bad on it
you would see the greatest gift would be
from me and the card attached would say
happy birthday you had a sweet note
inside which I'll treasure did it was
very sweet and I will only keep for
myself because people can play mostly
interested in the records though people
complained let me just say this people
complained about my birthday wish to you
on on the internet gram not being sappy
enough SAP you know I saw that I would I
think it was funny this year that was me
man he's 41 guy has an account so no one
cares and I commented as if I were a fan
of myself III got sappy at 40 I'll get
sappy at 50 right the next nine years
you're gonna have to just deal with mild
comedy you put some of that in the car
and I appreciate it again it's not for
public consumption and I do take issue
make it sound like I I mean I didn't say
anything embarrassing it wasn't like a
sext or anything
I mean your wife wrote on one side you
wrote on the other side yeah it felt you
wrote on the left side so it felt like
you wrote yours first I did so you
didn't write anything that it would have
been really awkward if she read it I'll
put it to you that way I don't think
there's anything that I could have
written that if she had have happened to
open the card not planning on writing in
it that would have been awkward a sext
would fall in that category I don't
think I've got I don't think I've got
that in me so I don't know if you
noticed but I met everybody at the door
and I took the records I took the record
and they would put on and it would be
wrapped and I would immediately unwrap
it
and because I was that's why I was very
itching might I say that one of our
friends brought you records and you gave
them you said I got all these and gave
them right back I felt bad this is ward
I mean well here's what were saying he
was like you don't you don't do that no
he said listen man before I opened the
records he was like listen man I hope
you don't have this I don't know if you
have it if you have it just tell me
that's what he said
and then you joined the conversation
when I'm telling him I'm like yeah man I
got this one and but actually he gave me
two he gave me a used Merle Haggard
album and he gave me a brand new a Cyril
turtle Simpson a sailor's guide to
whatever it is which you have I actually
have the Moreau went to but I lied and
said oh I don't think I have this one
oh so I 50% lied because that was the
used one but the new one I felt bad that
he spent all that money and a new record
did say if you've got it I'll take it
because I want this yes he did he did
say right after you told him after he
kind of saw the look on your face he's
he's really gonna give this back my dad
is the exact same way by the way when he
opens a gift I grabbed this he's like
this is ugly you picture this on me like
tie my clothes at Christmas like he's
notorious yeah he'll go through the
trouble of trying it on to prove to you
house - how bad of a gifted it runs in
the family folks it runs in the family
so you get it ain't me I mean look I'm
trying to stand natural but it well I
just don't feel right in it
that's not tough person to give a gift
to now the reason my gifts were so
perfect is because your wife sent me a
list yeah yeah I got Low End Theory
Midnight Marauders haven't listened to
them yet Sufjan Stevens the Avalanche
with Neil Young Harvest Moon oh you're
gonna list them all some of it for the
Instagram okay well there's more and I
got you all new records man yeah they're
all plastic wrap all out
however the Steely Dan album that you
recommended as one of your wrecks
recently
Asia Asia you specifically requested the
be pressing not the a a pressing right
which they didn't have the a be pressing
they had some very nice a a pressings
that were plastic rafting like 30 bucks
apiece and I don't relate to my reddit
research yeah I I looked it up when I
was in there I looked it up I looked up
the reddit thread while I was in the
store because I was like first of all
what does this mean and is this what I'm
thinking it is apparently different
pressing sound dramatically different
corner and heretic and once you read
that stuff given my personality type I
can't ignore it
so I just couldn't have the the a a
pressing on my shelf knowing that reddit
says that it's inferior it's also very
rare and you're not gonna buy it at
amoeba ah because they're like a hundred
bucks I think if you can find one I
think you might be able to find one on
eBay it's part of the phone I mean I'm
getting back and I was so excited about
it because the collection aspect of my
life has been fallow for decades like
you know how I like to collect things
over the especially as a child mm-hmm
you know and still being a 41 year old
child in Lily's birthday card to me she
was like happy 44th birthday but I know
you're still a 10 year old basically
it's like this is coming from my 16 year
old daughter yeah I mean I had to resist
like I actually every time I go on to me
but first of all if you come to LA you
should go to amoeba music because it's
it's and there's one in San Francisco as
well right it's unlike any other music
store it's just massive and if concerts
and people play live in there they also
have books by the way I didn't I've
never been to the section with the books
and the graphic novels and the games I
actually went to the game section so I
was like oh this week link said he
wanted me to bring games I couldn't find
a game to bring but I bought some books
for myself but yeah you should go
because it's just it's it's it's a
unique experience but when I was in
there I thought to myself I have to
resist that part of my personality which
said like looks at the machine they're
like the record players and the speakers
and sees that all there's a whole world
here there's a whole there's a whole
world that you could get into and you
know I like to get into
I'm like well this one's easy because
links already into that so I can't also
get into that but I like I walk through
there I see you know and I'm so tempted
to sit there and like look at these did
you record players admit to all the
stuff that you get into is basically
because you know you're gonna trap me in
it no no no no that's part of it
no I'm saying that like I don't think
it's the kind of thing that's just like
it's one thing to be like oh I'm getting
into surfing or off-roading and
something that you can like do as you
can be like all this go together
together but like but will you trade
records we could swap records you can
own half the amount of records and plus
then you could do like you did with your
lights and you could be like hey look I
went out and got lights - I got record I
got a record player - but mine's better
than your but you can't just like you
did with the life but you can't voice
control a record player Google will not
know what to do it you could then you're
gonna get that so that you can tell me
that you had a better record player I
but also I don't have a spot for it yeah
you know yeah yeah I don't have a my
house is set up in a kind of an a weird
way where I don't have like let it be my
fake place come over any time you know I
was gonna let it be your thing until you
just told her that maybe it should be my
thumb soon you're off the hook I don't
want to spend the money okay I don't let
me pressure you how does give you good
records I didn't say - let it be my
favorite hey you know what just let it
be my thing yeah I'm going to get in a
popsicle for building about that I got a
spot for that not a lot else to say
about the party once I open all the
presents in my mind it was pretty much
over yeah everybody was still hanging
out and like there was a lot of quality
conversation to be had well we did
introduce all of our friends to Jim
Baker's buckets right but by the end
that's when I served but the end of the
night so I don't know how we got on this
but by the end of the night we brought I
started talking about it in a group with
people and by the end of the night we
were gathered around a television
watching Vic burgers edits of Jim
Baker's buckets and they were all just
first of all people kept walking in and
every person who would walk in would not
it first realized that it was an edit
and they thought that it was original
and so all the weird stuff that Victor
GERD first of all Jim Becker's buckets
infomercials are weird enough on their
own and we their owns if you don't know
what it is we did a taste test on the
show you can watch that or I'll just
tell you that famous 80s televangelist
Jim Baker has now made a comeback from
scandals and that's an understatement to
then use fear-mongering of the
apocalypse and the the rapture meaning
like the end of the world and those who
are gonna survive it if they believe the
right things or whatever are gonna have
to survive off of lots of slop that he
sells for like thousands of dollars well
I think they're pretty I think you'd get
a pretty good deal on them I mean that
was really fun but it kind of killed my
party honestly whenever we ran out of
videos to watch ever I was like well I
gotta go home and then the only person
that stayed there was Ginny and me and
jenni hung out for with Christie and
Mike we hung out front of hour and a
half where she proceeded to summarize
the plot of every Twilight movie to me
you talk about opening up a world you
don't know if you want to dip a toe in
how does such a thing happen she's
obsessed with Twilight I love her to
death and I was just like getting a kick
out of it you know how Ginny o get on a
roll about something and I I just got
her well I was talking about how Edward
Cullen or whatever his name is
who's that word comes is her hands your
mother's ring
no I'm talking about the guy who played
the vampire in Twilight his real name
Robert Pat rotten Pattinson
rotten rotten past you know Rob
Pattinson
he's the new freakin Batman what you
didn't know this this is old news homie
man I work too hard to know about stuff
like that gosh anyway summertime take
your socks off
chill out anyway I was talking about
Robert Pattinson being the new Batman
and then I knew that would get her all
in a heat wave and now rode that wave
for an hour I did not know all the crazy
stuff that happens
but now you know it because a woman
who's watched all of them just say she
was like I already lit for you I was
like you know what I kind of do tell me
the whole story tell me the whole thing
yeah in 90 minutes that's how I ended my
44th 14th speak all right let's talk
about the dogs I'm done with my birthday
I talk about it you know because we have
to we've simply got to get to the dogs
we've got to be linear because as you
said Jessie ended up leaving from the
party to go directly to LA well if she
went home went to LAX went to New
Orleans with some friends left me with
the children for four or five days and
golly man are you gonna say you almost
killed your dog when you were in charge
of your family no the dog thing actually
happened before so we'll come back to
that but I'm just gonna tell you a
little bit about what it was like to
care for my children and it was
especially it was complicated by
something that I'm not proud of that
you're gonna you you don't you know what
you don't even have to say anything
I hate boys I tell this story you don't
have to say anything I know you're gonna
want to say a lot I'm not gonna
interrupt I'm only gonna give a
supportive facial expression we filmed
something on Thursday of last week
that's why I turned our parking lot into
a water park
geenie lies ready to get wet and I did
what I have done many many times since
getting an iPhone 10 and that is I got
my phone wet in fact I get my phone wet
so often that I regularly film under the
water in my pool and in my hot tub
because it says that it's
water-resistant but I watched a YouTube
video where a guy basically said you
know for all intents and purposes the
iPhone 10 is waterproof and here's
here's and then he does all these tests
he put it in the bottom of a pool for
like three hours and he kept testing it
longer and longer and longer and pulled
it up and so after watching that video I
came to the conclusion that it's
actually waterproof but they have to say
water-resistant for legal
purposes but you should just treat it as
if it's waterproof well that's all wrong
I can't believe you're telling the story
you're not gonna let me say anything
go ahead you know what tell your story
and so I got into a tub with my phone in
my back pocket and I didn't even think
to check my phone because again this is
just another day of my phone getting wet
this is just what I do with my phone
it wasn't until like two hours later
when I was like oh I might need to check
my phone for something that I pulled it
up and it just had the Apple logo on it
and I was like no no no no this can't
happen what about the video with the guy
in the pool and the 30 feet and all that
well it ruined my phone which do you
want to say something yes can I please
say anything you want what about the
middle of the story what did it involved
me talking to you about your phone
before you did what you did but you
didn't even eat you were about to sit
down in the tub and I said I said we're
shooting and I said don't be alarmed I
have my phone in my pocket and I'm gonna
sit in the water so so don't worry I
don't I've made a filming I'm making the
decision to do this and then you said I
know you're gonna say that the iPhone
what you just said I know you're gonna
say that the iPhone is water-resistant
but not waterproof and they but listen I
I know it's fine up and then you said
everything that you said but you left
out that part and I said listen I I just
wouldn't I just I don't do that I don't
take that risk he's like yeah I put it
down in the bottom of the thing and
everything so you're the type of person
who you don't trust the phone you don't
trust you you're missing out man you put
it on me and you well said that
because you made me you usually didn't
seem like what I was about to do is
wrong anticipated that I was gonna judge
that you were doing something stupid and
I didn't even say all I all I said was I
don't even think I said anything and in
one sense you preemptively here's a dude
with me and I wasn't even argue with it
and once it killed your phone in one
sense you have missed out all the times
that I filmed underwater up until that
point it was unreal you shouldn't you
know I should look at some of my word
you should look at some of the videos I
haven't said a word about so might I say
you said you even if if you would have
listened back to your story you blamed
the phone you got to take some of the
blame well I am I am serving a warning
to anyone who has a who has a I phone 10
I don't know now according to my son the
iPhone XR or whatever it is he was like
no dad the iPhone said everything you
know from your son oh yeah well you
should listen to him more he was like no
dad that iPhone 10 is not as waterproof
as the i-x are or whatever even though
the one in that frickin video was an
iPhone 10 because I watched it in that
was what gave me the confidence that I
then took into that tub I'm gonna sit
down in this tub and I don't I want to
acknowledge that my phone's gonna be in
my pocket I'm doing it on purpose
don't stop the filming because I got
this I do it all the time now and don't
argue with me you're the one missing out
in my desk now it went in my defense a
note on an import or after in my defense
what I was saying was is I am taking
responsibility for the action that I'm
taking so if you tell me when you just
retold the story no no that's what I'm
doing it on the phone you blamed it on
the guy who made the video well it you
blamed it on the water can we move on I
I'm this is fun the point I think maybe
for you the point of the story is that
I've been holding this in the iPhone 10
is not waterproof it is water resistant
and no point ever said it we want to
prove that that guy you can push it
don't push it so what this led to is
thankfully my phone was insured but I
don't have Apple care so I can't just go
to the store it was just it was through
like the the insurance you get through
your carrier right so which means you
get it next day but there was a problem
with the flight there was a flight delay
and so I didn't get it on Friday which
means I had to wait until Monday which
mean I wasn't gonna have my phone for
four days it's a flight that the phone
was on yeah because it was overnight
from like Kentucky or wherever they keep
these phones and not having my phone
which incidentally we have like the
social iPhone here which I was able to
put my sim card in which is weird
because you can't just take your sim
card and put it into another phone
you'll get some texts but you don't get
all texts your phone doesn't work
properly unless you like completely like
put all your stuff submerge it in water
yeah you got to keep it in water right
but that made to caring for children and
I said this in a tweet at some point is
mostly driving them places at their age
yeah they have to be so many freaking
places why do they have to be so many
places what what happened if you're not
quite ready to get there themselves what
just what happened it just being at home
and making fun for yourself why do you
gotta have art camp and basketball
practice and then another thing and then
why you got to hang out with your
friends what you know okay
so driving around not having a
functioning phone my wife got home after
she got home last night
actually and she walked in the door and
she said why does the house smell like
feet I was like listen that is the last
thing that I'm worried I'm just glad
that I have a phone that works now that
you're back they're not dead they went
to stuff we had good times together
you know they I ain't having lunch which
I never and having like lunch in the
middle of the day was Shepherd but I was
able to do that three days and we was
we had a great time but it's I don't
know and when she asked a question by
the feet my honest answer was I don't
know why it smells like feet and I don't
know why you being here means it doesn't
smell like feet like I honestly can't I
you you think it's simple you think it's
like Oh dorita you think it's things
like we left socks out or something no
everything was properly disposed of it
was just something about me and my boys
being together in a home for an extended
period of time that just made us my life
feat stress
what was it where's it coming from it's
not coming from my feet I don't know I
don't even wear socks I have wicking
kind of wicking shoes I think it's just
the stress of you have the weight of
responsibility being on your shoulders
for once it just eats out in like a foot
smell man I was just so glad not not
that I don't listen I don't want to I'm
not trying to give the wrong idea as if
like well when when my wife's in town
she's the one that worries and I'd about
the kids and I don't do anything I'm
just saying when there is when it's all
on you and I sympathize man because I
was the thing was I wanted to talk about
this I wanted to show this because what
I was doing I thankfully I was able to
stay I was able to work from home and we
are currently look at this look at this
we have what they call the bound the
galley of the loss causes a bleak reek
our novel that comes out in the fall
October 29th you can pre-order right now
at Bleak Creek calm hey so what we're
doing right now is we're going through
this and it's kind of the last time that
we can read it and edit it before it's
completely locked you want to you want
to read it right now and so I was able
to do that from home well pictures made
it where I could you know I could do the
things that I needed to do take the kids
to where I needed to take them and then
kind of fill in the gaps with oh it's
cut oh there's a chapter xix close that
boy would do people gonna zoom in on
that man oh yeah people definitely gonna
zoom in on that you're gonna have to
blur that keiko you know what I'll blur
it I'll do it myself it's my fault so I
don't know how many times I have now
read the
book there was a point in which I was
like I've read this book so many times I
know you know I know everything
obviously I know every single thing
that's gonna happen but so from like at
this point one of the things that I'm
doing in going through is making sure
that there's not like oh that phrase or
that particular word that descriptive
language was used and then it was used
again which is something you do like
especially if you're writing a novel for
the first time it's like you know when
you're using descriptive language you
may go to the same places and so going
into those places and making it and
changing it that's one of the things
I've been doing but it's like it's I'm
so familiar with it at this point that
I'll see a phrase and that'll be like or
I'll see like two words together and be
like those two words were together five
chapters ago let me go find that and let
me and so you get you're getting a
little too close to it yeah you're
getting a little too close I don't even
like it's like I read it I read it in
the day and a half in like a speed kind
of way because I also know what's
happening but I read it in Reverse to
make sure every word was spelled
correctly you know somebody is doing
that though but because I blurt it out I
mean really you did blur it out but I'm
gonna say I did I'll read an excerpt
from chapter 19 which is a chapter that
I held up he lay there in his teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle boxers which were
still slightly damp that's not a
complete sentence it continues but does
a little bit of a spoiler if I if I keep
reading that is a line and in the book
in chapter 19 you were you were saying
you were doing this and you were
building up to something I know I was
saying that was what I was doing oh well
I know it's I was saying I'm able to be
home single parents who are responsible
for children and have a job like my mom
was that is man I just I again I was
that for like four days and two of those
days were a weekend and I just felt like
I was just gonna go nuts I mean
hats off to those of you who are primary
caregivers working and raising children
without any help it ain't easy but I
want to know what happened to the to
your dog okay you said it was before
that it was I wonder if we're at this
point the day before she we left
oh we just went in the podcast where
it's like people are mad do we haven't
talked about our daughter this is like
this is like the old school like I
didn't mean Charles Trippy and Shay Carl
vlogs where it would be it would say
something in the title anyway where the
hell is that thing that they talked
about in the title yeah but this is like
40 and there are no rules just right
how Beck's take us I mean I think we've
had a great conversation except for that
part where you really got on me about my
phone I mean everything's been pretty
good the highlight for me the really
needed that I've been holding that in
for a while so right before Jesse left
she called me and she said well I just
got a call from a woman who said do you
own a little white dog and Jesse was
like uh uh yeah she said well I have her
right now and for fifty thousand dollars
you could ever back no that's a good
question how much would you we'll go
ahead so interestingly here's what
happened first of all Barbara is a
homebody
she is not there's a lot of dogs that
like if you open the door they bolt for
the door and they try to get in they'll
run right
Barbara's never done that in fact
sometimes we leave the door open if
we're like going down to the car and
Barbara would just come to the door like
if one person is a straggler and the
door still up and she'll just come to
the front door she might walk out onto
the front porch and like look at us but
only if she knows that she's going to be
in the car does she come down the stairs
and like get into the car and then never
has she gone down the driveway as a
pretty long driveway that's kind of
steep and she's never gone to the bottom
of the driveway however the other day
we've got some guys doing some work on
the house like redoing a bathroom and
they were they had their truck down at
the bottom of the hill down the driveway
they didn't drive up the driveway and
they were the guy was walking down the
driveway and Barbara just followed him
and got all the way down he didn't know
that she was following him and she got
all the way to the bottom and then at
that point I went outside and called her
back up and she came back up but at that
moment there was like a look in her eyes
which was like there's a whole world
beyond this and it scared me a little
bit but I didn't I didn't say anything
about it I didn't mention it to Jesse
well what Jesse did like Jim Carrey at
the edge of that bubble yep
haven't seen the movie but I kind of
know what it's about the truman show
excellent movie highly recommend it you
don't think so nice things anyway so
jesse was taking something to the car
left the door open
went back inside shut the door and it
was in that little window that somehow
Barbara had slipped out gone down the
driveway gone down the road walked rode
across an intersection not now we live
in suburban area so she didn't it's not
like she went across a busy intersection
but she went across an intersection that
was not a four-way stop like I'll put it
to you this way the there aren't painted
lines on the road in your neighborhood
right but there are intersections there
she could easily be run over by someone
who wasn't paying attention
and so the story that the woman told was
she said we were that's a long ways away
in my mind her having never left the
house a few houses down I mean six
houses down there's like two houses down
then across the street then a couple
houses up so she said we were driving on
the road and we saw her walking I don't
know if she was on I think she was
walking on like the side of the road and
we stopped cuz she she looked she's not
supposed to be alone she's woman she's
not a coyote which incidentally there
are coyotes in our neighborhood on our
on the Reg and so being out for that
long means that she could have been
snatched
really quickly oh yeah like it isn't
just getting run over it's his coyotes
like easily could happen I see all the
time walking on the street yeah
and so she the the the woman says we saw
her we stopped the car we opened the
door and she ran and jumped in the car
you can you can take me somewhere faster
so that is Barbara in a nutshell which
is stranger opens door it's like the
complete opposite of what we were told
to do in the 80s when it comes to
strangers yeah stranger opens door jump
in the car like and the thing is is that
she's luck she loves people so much and
she loves strangers the the fresher you
are the newer you are to her the more
she loves you and which I love that
about her hmm but it she's a liability
and now she understands there's a whole
world of people out there she doesn't
know about the Coyotes I can't tell her
about the code if you if you walk far
enough cars stop open doors and you can
go anywhere right like cars lead to
planes lead to like rockets and who
knows where she could go and first of
all thankfully we have Jesse's phone
number on our collar which if you don't
have your phone number on your dog's
dog's collar put it on there that's a
hot tip cuz even if you chip them who's
gonna scan a chip like people like
that's there's a delay in that you don't
know if people are actually gonna do it
what are they gonna do with your talk
put your phone number on the freaking
dog also get a will I've heard four on
two things that like you a dog will
obviously know what you should be doing
it but you just haven't gotten around to
doing it but like what Barbara's gonna
leave to I'm just saying your eyes if
you're human without a will you should
have one I think everything that Barbara
owns just defaults to us I'm talking
about humans no okay
Barbara's the remainder of Barbara's dog
food goes into a blind trust also Mike
and Tim we have to figure out what to do
it clean your gutters
you know you'll feel better so that was
my close call with Barbara and Bobby I
want to hear your close call with Jaden
and we can talk about what we would do
if the unthinkable happened I decided to
get out do a little hike
me and Christy went for a little hike it
was gonna be like a like a 1-hour thing
so I took Jade I don't take J I took
date on a couple of big hikes but now
I've started to feel a little guilty
about that because she's so small and
and she's not she's not that active yeah
but a small high like this I'll still
take her on and we're walking in some I
mean this is like in like a a Wilderness
Park area and dirt trails and whatnot
and there are signs like watch out for
rattlesnakes
I was very vigilant and we walk out and
there's this like watershed place where
they've got these like dams built up
there then the water will run and then
kind of go trickle or a trickle over it
but it's like there's a downpour down
like down the slope it won't just erode
a whole bunch of stuff mr. professor
mostly Joe but you can um you can walk
out on these dams and like I walked out
on one of these I have Jade on leash
Christie's behind me do not have her on
a leash she maybe should have me on a
leash hmm but she didn't this time never
anytime you guys don't get a leash the
not in parks so so we're out on the dam
and as I walk out there I see some some
no mat rattlesnakes but I see some bees
like coming out and buzzing around and
where they're bees there's honey yeah
what what were you gonna say
rattlesnakes babe honey that's to say
yeah it's more correct I wasn't thinking
about honey I wasn't thinking about bees
I'm like yeah there's bees you know I'm
not afraid of bees yeah you get real
skittish around bees Christy gets kind
of skittish yeah she's like there's bees
I think I was like yeah I think there
must be a hive down there and like they
were like buzzing around at my feet and
like going around my ankles it never
registered to me that every time Jade
sees a house fly in our house or like
one of those Little Miss big mosquitos
she it's her life mission to get it
until she's gotten it like she will
that's the most active I see her that's
when she's like hunting a housefly other
than that she just sits in my lap like
she's doing right now
didn't cross my mind until she starts
snapping at some bees and then she's
like shaking her head and like bat in
her face I'm like oh she got stung we
need it we need to get we need to get
off this ledge so I'm like how stupid
can you be put my dog in harm's way so I
like take the dog over there's a yeah I
think she got stung on the snout but
they weren't Africanized they weren't
letting ask him but they weren't they
weren't aggressive a weren't aggressive
because they were like they were buzzing
around my legs and I they weren't just
like a normal B they weren't aggressive
because that is but when she snapped at
the bee then once stung her I believe on
her snout but that is one thing you when
you're hiking in Southern California you
really have to be village' diligent
vigilant vigilant about that's even
better but if you if you're in a village
you could be village it right yeah I'm
not saying I'm like it's all about
ignorance is bliss I guess that's me on
a hike but I was looking for
rattlesnakes that took all of my inner
no but I'm sure eyeing you you you got
to be prepared like do not aggravate or
go close to once you see bees saal way
go away because yeah they could be
Africanized bonehead move them on
they'll chase for like a mile bees
didn't chase us but I feel of them were
swarming around Jade and she mighta got
stung twice but definitely wants on this
now and then we're so we walk off the
thing and then we're gonna walk up the
path a little bit more cuz I'm like yeah
we yeah I wasn't thinking that much of
it so I all she got stung by a bee if I
got stung by a bee
I would keep Heike and then she lays
down I'm like this isn't good she never
lays down on a hike we put some water
down she drank a lot of water and then
like come on let's go and then she like
she would not keep walking and like I
started to get concerned Chrissy's
already concerned you know she's got
that she's got good intuition she's like
yeah this isn't good pick her up and I
like pick her up she's very floppy and
like just putting her head down like I
started feel horrible that I led her to
this bee patch they're like strawberries
I guess and then I'm like like let's
turn around I mean we gotta we gotta get
back to the car she might she might need
treatment
and light we walk we walk a little bit I
put her down and this has been like five
minutes since she was stung we had
decided to turn around and she threw up
and then I'm like she said she could be
having allergic there any swelling but
there was no visual of swelling on the
snout or anywhere just lethargy vomiting
and floppiness and I'm starting to get
scared but I'm kind of in denial I'm
like I don't want to I don't want to
think the worst hear that like but
Chrissy's like her throat can swell up
you know she could take it down if she
has she's having a larger reaction so
walking down we're like calling the vet
and and looking googling as we're like
walking I'm like carrying her like a
she's like a lifeless little furball and
we're getting scared
and like it's a well the the vets in
surgery and Chrissy's like well can you
recommend somewhere else that we can go
there was another vet that we used to go
to in town and she's like we'll call
them unless like no they're in surgery
as well I'm like dang that's like to do
this afternoon surgery that's where the
big money is at the vet agreed to come
out of surgery and take a look so we
took her there and then they you know
the stinger if for like if it stays in
there can continue to pump venom even
after the bees gone away so you trip I
learned that you should try to get rid
of the stinger as but it wasn't there it
did it I think she batted it away
initially but she was having an allergic
reaction because she but the way she was
acting and vomiting and they gave her
they gave her benadryl and just told her
she's gonna told us she's gonna be
really sleepy
and it was like there was no sign of
swelling so they were like are you sure
she was talking about B were like yes
definitely but I didn't allow myself to
believe that this could be like a life
or death situation but I was certainly
hiking very fast back down to the car to
get her over there so it was pretty
scary but they they put us at ease and
you know haven't talked to the vet and
then she was just very lethargic for the
next 24 hours because of the benadryl
but
everything's fine now she's eating and
drinking fine and she's like she's right
here but she has a specific allergy to
bees is that what happened to any dog of
her size um no they said it was an
allergy for her to react that way I love
you too she gave me a kiss
she's still a little it's you know it's
been like 48 hours she's still a little
bit mopey but she's kind of mopey anyway
look at her she seems embarrassed it
wasn't your fault baby it was my fault
I shouldn't have let you into that patch
of bees should have known better and
then but you talk about hot tip he said
where did you go and we told the vet and
he said well you need to come back and
get a a rattlesnake venom vaccine which
I was like I didn't know this existed
and they were like yes rattlesnakes are
really bad there's a lot more rain in LA
now they're coming out like dogs are
coming in from dog parks getting bit by
rattlesnakes in dog parks and dying you
caught it you can hit a rattle sighs
rattle snake vaccine anything
can I get one he said that well he's a
vet you don't give it to humans I don't
I don't I didn't ask that question so I
don't know the answer but he said that
it doesn't all it does is gain you time
like an hour to get them to a vet that's
what the vaccine does so if you're if
you're in an area with with rattlesnakes
there is a such a thing as a rattlesnake
vaccine and it it gains them precious
time to get them to a vet well I'm
talking an hour because their bodies
can't take it small dog gets bit by a
relic I'm just not gonna take her out
anymore I think it it it kind of keep
her in a bowl of it you very well I mean
it's it's a little different than a
child you know it's like our children
you got to let them out into the world
and educate them about they got to take
care of themselves some rattlesnakes and
like make their own place but like she
you're gonna take care of her you can
baby her all you want that's right
that's why I walk her off him down the
stairs I put her in the bed I take her
out of the bed she she'll jump out of
the bed now and like she'll beg for
water in the middle of the night right
and so I start putting water into our
bathroom upstairs because you know I
live in a huge freakin man she takes for
a long ways down there to shoot
and water is without the same podcast we
still need to say yes I mean one might
argue that you know I should I should
encourage Barbara to go out on her own
and go and be with another family
because she's gonna have to do that one
day but she's not gonna do some one
night but she is gonna die I just I
would have been after she lives her very
long life I thought about I mean I love
Jade so much I think I've said this I
frequently in like my most tender
moments of snuggling I just
instinctively think about when she's
gone because it's like 15 years maybe
less I mean if I'm lucky she's gonna
pass on she's gonna go to doggy heaven
or hell she may go to doggy hell I don't
know what the criteria is for these
decisions here's a dozen going down but
she's so lazy she's mean she's mean
she's Meenakshi Barbara is very nice
other people just going to dog yes it's
not like the woman who figure out what
in a literal angel or God because the
neighbor of yours
she hasn't that woman has no bearing on
whether your dog is a heaven or hell but
I find myself thinking you haven't lost
a dog as an adult I have because you
didn't you haven't had a you haven't had
a dog she would have died from the honey
bee I would I literally thought when we
got her back home I was like if that
would have happened I would have been
out of commission for at least I mean a
solid week of I'm not leaving the house
I'm not I don't believe that I think you
would be I think you'd be in mourning
for a long time but I don't think you
would be like I can't come in to work
for a week I think you I think you
probably what's what I thought that's
what I feel but I don't think would be
easy right then I would say I got to get
out of here I'll try to for know in the
book of mythicality
I talked extensively about this about
the McLaughlin family dog curse and how
right growing up we had two dogs run
away and then as an adult I've had two
dogs die and then we went for over it
well over a decade without having a dog
because of this curse now Barbara a few
things about Barbara number one she's
been around significantly longer than
any other dog and she's only been around
for like three
years or so our relationship with her is
way different and better than the
relationship that we had with the other
dogs
I mean Merle our first dog as a couple
died as a like in the first year and
then [ __ ] our second dog who know maybe
was other way around gypsy was the first
dog she was a rescue that I literally
found like on the side of the road and
rescued and kept I did because she
didn't have her owners number I couldn't
call her an owner's number so I just
kept it for myself no but it was she was
like an abandoned puppy in the woods and
she made it like a year and then died
and when she died
Jessie was pregnant at the time and when
she died like that night she died at the
beach she got ran over at the beach and
that we like just set in laid in the bed
and cried and then like the rest of the
trip was kind of like clouded by this
and then there would be times over the
next couple months where we would think
about her I would like I would think
about her and I would get sad maybe
almost cry or like get teary-eyed but
how was the quality of relationship that
you had with gypsy compared to Barbra
now not even close right
so because I think we you approach dogs
differently is there's all kinds of
things that are different like it's it's
been a longer period of time Barbara is
a is she's a special dog she's a special
dog like she's the most affectionate dog
I've ever met and like you know we have
our stretch in snuggle time in the
morning right get my back and do my
stretches and she snuggles with me and
then she of course our kids I didn't
observe
I don't recall observing a connection
like you have with Barbara that and I
think he would be devastating I think
there's a trope --is-- stage of life
thing that like for sure that dads go
through and sure
I've never had a dog with it my only
daughter is Barbara okay but it was
difficult but you know how much more
difficult gonna be it would be it would
be devastating but and listen I there is
no there is no comparison in my mind
there's absolutely no comparison
obviously losing a child would be like
that's like that's the worst thing that
can happen everybody I can't imagine
anything worse than that that that is
the worst thing that could happen to you
and they're not even I don't think
they're in the same ballpark by any
means because with a with a dog
you kind of know this dog is like you
said Jade's existence and Barbara's
existence in your family has reached a
stasis that it will basically be at
until she starts to get older and
feebler but she's pretty much who she's
gonna be she's fully expressed she's
good and she's gonna live a maximum of
something teen years right and you know
that that's gonna happen so if it
happens earlier it would be devastating
but it's still not a drastic like
upheaval in what you're planning for
your dog and the way that you plan for
another human in your life and so I
think that there's a there's a period of
mourning but then you're kind of like
okay I'm gonna get another dog I don't
want to downplay that the morning but I
do think that I I'm interested in in
feedback so hashtag ear biscuits but I
think I know may have mentioned this
there are times that I think about
getting a second dog and I do think that
that's that's part of I'm interested in
that being part of the strategy if at a
certain point in introducing a second
dog so there's like overlap there can be
overlap so it's like you know if Jade's
I don't know not not too old not like
okay I got a I got it like a year or
something I got a
I haven't I'm more of an overlap than
that I kind of feel like that would help
a little well we could be but I could be
told I've never been through this and I
think it does help because we've got
friends who have who had dogs that were
I think weren't Max & Ruby brother and
sister yeah and our friend Nick had two
dogs that like they were he's very
attached to yeah and he lost one you
know they lost both he lost actually
losing the second one I don't know I'd
have to ask him what was what was know
but I was but I definitely think that it
being able to be like we've still got a
dog to go from and having a dog to
having no dogs I think would be or a pet
you know I obviously this also applies
to cats those of you who can make those
kinds of emotional connections to cats
the same thing applies in fact my my son
very magnanimous my son has a friend
whose cat recently died and he had in
like it was you know as a cat had been
around for a very long time and they or
the family had a very difficult time
Lincoln had a friend who came to school
talking about how his dog died and
everyone was sad and like Lincoln cried
for his friend and then turns out the
dude was joking and then a few weeks
later his dog actually died yeah that's
what happens to you joke about your dog
dying it's gonna happen just like he
says manifested full circle that was
still this podcast yeah we've been on
quite a journey right uh why cried for a
friend that is a high level of empathy
I'm yeah when what context he's like I'm
crying right now he talked about the dog
I'm dying and he just started he started
crying in front of him or later he he
teared up
that's unusual what he was yeah yeah
well I don't it's not unusual for
Lincoln I think that's just you know
given his connection with Jade and I'm
saying it's unusual for a teenage boy to
be told about someone else's dog dying
India cry I'm saying I as the father of
a teenage boy and who knows a lot of
teenage boys I'd say that's unusual I'm
saying it's a good thing but it's not
normal it's it's it's good it's like a
you would want other kids to have that
level
yeah I'm glad I'm glad he did it
especially just so his friend could turn
on the stamp on it and say he was just
joking yeah baby I'll never cry for your
dog again jerk I did ask him so when his
dog really did die did you he left how
do you naturally yeah it's like assuming
they joking it's like and I can you know
I can have a dark sense of humor so I
reserve the right to joke about J dine
that doesn't you know and again that and
I thought that's okay I think it's okay
and I think you think it it demonstrate
my coping that it might be a coping
mechanism but it also demonstrates that
there's a fundamental difference between
a relationship with an animal in a
relationship with a human I can't joke
about anybody dying and then feel the
you know it's like well I'm not gonna do
it currently but like I can I joke about
death but then I think it puts it in its
place but there are lots of people who
talk about their relation people who
don't have children who have pets I
guess I'm taking up for Lincoln's know
there are people who don't have children
but have pets and sometimes we'll start
talking to people who have children and
talking about their pets as if there are
children as if they can relate to having
children because they have a pet pets
and children ain't nearly the same thing
but but you can get an inkling of that I
mean I'm not gonna say that there's not
some no you can't I is not fun I highly
disagree having a child and having a pet
are not in the same ballpark being okay
you're responsible for another B yes
that's true but I'm not so minimizing
what happens if you've got a pet I'm
saying what you're saying is true except
that the that there is a connect there's
a connection I think you can lose
something precious to you that's not
even living and it's in in some I I
wouldn't then access that
conversationally with someone who's lost
a child I'm not saying that I'm not
minimizing what I'm saying is that for
those people this is unrelated to the
thing dying what I'm saying is is if
you're in a conversation with somebody
who's got you're like man I had to you
know I it was kind of crazy like my son
just went through a really
difficult time at school would double
Evelyn they're like yeah my my dog has
hip dysplasia it's like they're not in
the same it's okay
I'm not saying that's easy but it's not
like having a child to go through
something this different man as someone
who's got children and pets
yes different what all I'm saying is I
think people who don't have kids can
then they can access empathy through an
experience that they have of loving a
pet yeah I don't have a daughter like I
said I'm the one who said a second ago
that Barbara's my daughter I tell her
she could be anything she wants to be
she's gonna go to doggy college she's
gonna have a great doggy career are you
going to what do you think about the
overlap in order to prepare you know
it's not worth it hmm I don't want to I
don't want to deal with two dogs plain
is simple I Barbara is I don't want to
decide the little attached to humans
well that's not a problem he's got three
kids you didn't divide the love between
them it's yeah I did not I'm not I'm not
no I just don't that when we travel and
figuring out what to do it's like if
we're gonna take them on a walk like
adding an extra dog into the mix it's
the same reason I've only got two kids
and not three so you know I want to
minimize that I want the I want to enjoy
the benefits of having a pet and then
start over afterwards and then yeah and
maybe and maybe take a relatively long
break before the next one
I don't know well depends on what stage
life I'm in I I think that makes me
think that maybe I should just I
shouldn't get another dog in order to
not go through the pain of losing you
get another dog if you want another dog
yeah period yeah you shouldn't use it
you shouldn't use a dog as a as a as a
death bridge and some people think you
should get another dog depending on the
breed for the companionship of the dog
like I said our dogs neither one of them
need that that's clear
yeah they're plenty our dogs do not know
that they're dogs
so getting another dog would be like
what is this dog doing here
you know why did you get a dog did you
get me a dog what made you guys think
that we needed a
it's what our dogs would that's that's
almost like when you said that I
pictured a meme of Barbara with another
dog there there's a good meme like yeah
it's like that's funny somebody do that
make a meme but given the event of time
that we've taken we need to hear your
Rec oh my gosh my Rec is I look for an
app to catalogue my record collection on
my phone because now that I'm back in
the collection mode I want to know what
that was and I went around to a bunch of
like cute different apps and then I came
back to the one that everyone talks
about on the vinyl reddit thread and
that's Discogs
which is kind of a marketplace for
buying and selling of records but I just
use it too it's a way for me to carry my
record collection with me at all times
see look I can just I can just scroll
well I guess the pictures don't show up
if you're in airport mode but like the
pictures usually show up and sometimes
when I get bored and I want to feel good
about myself I look at my record
collection I just kind of like scroll it
can you click on it boosts my my Chi can
you click on that and would this be so
just if you clicked on that and you
could play them on your phone like the
digital version of those songs go
against the whole I think you're
describing Spotify no it cannot do that
no but if you wanted to be like oh this
is my record collection this is the
songs that I own oh I want you to hear
this song but we're not currently at my
record player that feels like you should
I mean I yeah you could just go one app
over but if you want to experience the
album as intended look at that yeah you
can't do that but you can make a wish
list and then you can buy off there how
do you listen to your record player I'm
trying to do it more often now that I
got these right because every time I
come over to your house
you're just playing Spotify yeah because
it goes throughout the whole house it's
a different it's you have to have a
listening session it's like it takes
discipline a little bit of planning and
then I'll do it when I'm drinking coffee
on a weekend morning and I've started
trying to do it like sometimes during
dinner we'll play like a record but then
in the middle of it I got to get up and
flip the record but I all of that is
jukebox all of that jukebox
oh that's part of it I and it's like the
negative the things that you could point
out is negative aspects of record
listening I'm just trying to figure you
can make them positive that's about the
convenience it's about the art and if
you just want to if you want to get a
little boost even when you're apart from
your record collection you can get
discogs and if you're doing some crate
digging you won't buy doubles do you
feel a noticeable tangible difference
between the vinyl songs and the digital
songs nope and red wine is red wine but
I you know I know I aspire to be able to
have an opinion on red wine and I kind
of and I actually did do an a/b test it
I mean yes it sounds different you could
if I you know if you walked into Norman
you would know which one was which I
think I would yeah yeah on the same
speeders could you see the record
spinning she would tell ya you can tell
a difference you can tell a difference
but I mean I think being able to tell
the difference is I'm not gonna say that
makes me a cooler a better person but I
am kind of implying that do you listen
to records and drink a red wine at the
same time I haven't I said but you're
gonna be like drinking like barefoot
wines Charles oh I'd say charles schwab
hi I love what well what's to buck chuck
Charles what Charles Chuck I don't know
Charles is the cheapest wine you can get
I thought when you said barefoot I
thought you literally were talking about
because my feet were so sweaty for
wearing shoes all day drinking barefoot
lime listening to yeah something
barefoot Mountain Boys barenaked ladies
you guys Charles Shaw yeah that's my rec
get some Charles Shaw get your records
discogs hashtag ear biscuits thanks for
letting us shoot the breeze with you
yeah don't give us any crap about
waiting so late to the answer the
question okay don't give rent any crap
about to think about his phone that's
right I didn't think I didn't tell you
is that the replacement phone that I got
he's messed up not because I put it in
water because I'm not doing that again
because why are you not doing that again
well the way insurance works is they
give you a refurbished phone and
everything about it seems completely
normal and new like you see that screen
there's not a scratch on it the face ID
will not activate which is a problem
that is usually a hardware problem so
every time you look at your phone to try
to get it activate you think about that
moment when you told me I've got this
and I'm gonna have to do it again Oh
trust me you don't have to say anything
this is one of those situations where I
learned my lesson without it you having
to say anything at all
well now that you think that you should
you just couldn't persist but well that
you said that the world will keep
resisting to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]